according to stock picker and Arc invest
CEO Kathy with technology companies are
cutting jobs as they harness the new AI
tools and other Technologies to increase
productivity and provide new products
and services with States
stated that these layoffs should not be
viewed as a sign of Technology sector
being in this array but instead as a
correction from over hiring during the
height of the pandemic more than 300
Technology firms including Amazon Apple
Zoom Dell and IBM have seen layoffs in
2023 nearly a hundred thousand job Cuts
since the beginning of the year the
beginning of the year was just six weeks
ago five weeks ago it's not like the
beginning of the year according to what
AI is playing a role in the layoffs
as it provides new avenues for
amplifying productivity would even
predicted that by 2030 Amazon will have
more robotic employees than humans so
Vinnie our AI expert what do you think
is pausing please because you're right
so tell us what it is
just just think about it because uh so
who was talking about it yesterday I
think it was on on Rogan's podcast that
the new update the part four of the chat
gbt is coming out the way that they were
talking about Lex Friedman it's
scary that in the next 10 15 years
they're literally going to take over and
so it's going to ruin uh Society because
everybody's going to be unemployed
people are going to have the jobs and
that I don't know about that I'm just
that's what that well think about Pat I
think it has to do with love if right
now you have somebody writing a story
that I could easily just type in chat
gbt and then just tweak it a little bit
why do we need that human being doing it
you know what I mean so so you you're
right I think the the thing to uh uh put
there is the the reaction so for example
uh we can come up with content here we
can get chat gbt to give us a script on
what to put up there for what do you
call it
um uh you know how to respond to this if
somebody says this how do you respond to
that and how do you respond to that okay
great you can put that on there there's
no problems with that we are enamored by
human beings who independently can do
things that others cannot do we're
enamored by that Hollywood acting if you
can act a role and get me to believe in
the movie fences when you watch Denzel
you don't love me I don't love you yeah
you hey you have the other issue you see
that and but you've seen five other
people do that part that was done Years
Ago by the famous legendary actor who
passed away you know like what a great
you see Leo when he does the bear on top
of him before the 19 year old girl this
beer was on time that one movie what is
the movie's name the government uh what
is the name of the movie with the you
know what I mean what's his name Tom
Hardy when he lives oh yeah he cut the
real horses
by the way you hear Tony Robbins speak
and he's like moving an audience and
he's you know are you here Antonio
Robinson listen forgive me for you know
that's a whole different story by the
way you watch that all right you watched
Steve Harvey tell a story have you seen
Steve Harvey tell a story can move it I
gotta tell you Steve Harvey is maybe one
of the top 10 best storytellers in the
world today when he tells a story you
could find yourself seven minutes later
saying what the hell did I do just the
last seven minutes yeah you so Chachi BT
cannot do that because you don't see the
emotion behind the machine we are not
turned on by machines have you ever
physically been turned on by a machine
and say man I'm emotionally attached it
to this this doesn't mean there's an
entire billionaire industry I was just
gonna say Rob once
the fear with technology has been around
for a long time yeah and and and the one
thing with us as we age Vinnie yeah and
we start worrying about uh end of the
world and you know and you start talking
about these kids are lazy and they don't
know when you start making comments like
that that's the first sign of you
getting gold I'm getting old 100 but
here's my thing though I'm talking about
20 years from now because mind you we're
not in the beginning stages it's this
thing is getting smarter and smarter
smarter yeah Pat the robot you know I
saw in China they have wrote they had
dude I saw a fleet of these Chinese
robots and it's I oh I went to a
restaurant with Kelly a couple weeks ago
yeah I'm not joking they had like one or
two servers we ordered the food a robot
came out with everything gave us our
food gave me my drink and I was like can
I get a refill yes the thing left
brought me my I'm not was this robot hot
I'm gonna tell you something right now
what was her name did you get her number
I don't know I don't know the name of it
but I like
I look [__] robots here
Hot Pot Wars Korean I mean they're
Advanced bro but Pat what a little it's
a little cart you know that you know
Roomba that runs around your I have one
I have one I have a relationship with
them I'm single but picture a Roomba
that kind of has a little radar in it so
it doesn't run into Furniture it just
kind of goes around with a with a big
post on it and a platter on top and
you're yeah they put your food on it no
but but Tom when it dropped off my food
it kind of looked back to me and it went
like it made like a noise that robot was
into me yeah I think I think Pat is
basically sort of winked when you get a
Diet Coke refill yeah I think Pat is
saying that certain elements of humanity
cannot be replaced so for instance I
agree you know we went to lunch a few
weeks ago to a restaurant called Hooters
yeah shout out to our friends at Hooters
hi girls I don't think there's ever
gonna come a time then Ai and robots are
gonna make it called rooters okay like
the robots aren't taking over Hooters
you remember your Yahoo
you're gonna be an old I remember the
podcast I'm telling you right now it's
not gonna happen soon but I'm saying
it's happening because I think some of
these jobs are going do you think do you
think so okay so let's find this because
I think there's there is fetishes like I
have I had a i when you're in the Army
you learn about a lot of weird things
with people with fetishes because when
you're doing late night guard duty of
course you've done that before you're
like what are you doing bro hey man dog
it's my finish you know can we keep this
time I get at least you know dude
anyways I'm not going to get into
specifics yeah but classic but but
here's the part here's the part finishes
fine but I want I want to ask you this
question let's let's say 30 years from
now okay you're 69 years old 30 years
from now however I'll be 70. you're
going to be seven 70 okay 30 or 30 years
from now you're going to be 70. okay
you're at a restaurant for like 75 74.
shot like we're doing like particulars
you go to a restaurant seven years from
now 30 years when you go to a restaurant
okay
and at this point this restaurant is
known
for having the hottest robots in the
world okay by the way technology is so
Advanced that they are 100 scored in a
way where what men think is beautiful
they look just like that their skin
feels like regular skin they have every
feature yeah a woman has yes she comes
and serves you food okay
you flirt with her yeah I know I am
would you hook up with a robot 100 100
am I gonna get a virus I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna have a feature though if they
don't like you that robot can cut it as
well if she doesn't like Bobby John it's
gonna be like oh boom one time you're
going that at that age that thing isn't
even well no with the way technology is
going to be working when you're dead
well with the reverse aging pill I might
be but listen in 30 years can you even
imagine how hot like I'm not gonna lie
are you gonna care like are you would
you hook up with a robot I have 100 with
some of the videos that I've seen yeah
100 Vinnie you would hook up with a
robot yes I would and it's been 30 years
from now in 30 years I'm telling you
guys your Yahoo Google you're gonna
change your tune yeah in 30 years what
these robots are listening you know
consider me old school I just kind of
like hooking up with regular human women
you're saying that you're saying that in
2020 old school like you're saying in
2023 in 2060 yeah trust me your tune is
going to change bro that's it you're
leading the low bro the robot Brigade of
uh marketing to start banging robots I'm
gonna be I'm not saying bang robots I'm
saying I'm gonna be an old man by them
but what I'm telling you is that
technology is going to be ridiculous
because they're going to look
spectacular I saw what I was doing
something on the podcast was going to be
funny I saw one of those ones that just
sits on your couch it looked ridiculous
it was it wasn't like robotic just wait
30 years you see what's gonna happen do
I see your face earlier you're like wait
what you'll see I'll show you one have
you seen that one more half or ahead of
this thing how did we get here we were
talking about I'd love to get a bell
question he asked the question he says
how much of this is AI I said here's
what Kathy Wood said about it then I
said here's our AI expert Vinnie and
then he went talking about Robot porn
and then we're here later can I make one
point about our friend whatever okay
bring it back to the point yeah I think
I think you know we tend to forget we
just went through a worldwide pandemic
for two years where it was like what
goes up must come down
money printing inflation Insanity
lockdown supply chain with like this was
the the global economy stopped for a
full-on year especially depending on
where you were in the world and things
are kind of restarting again and Kathy
said everyone thinks the technology
sector is in disarray but here it is
instead this is just a correction from
over hiring during the height of the
pandemic Kathy Wood I never heard her
name prior to 2000. she was one of the
darling investors of covid okay I'm
gonna ask you Vinnie does the name Eric
Juan ring a bell
everyone
no okay he's the CEO founder of Zoom he
went from a relatively
Unknown man to arguably the most needed
famous man in the world at one point
because he's the founder of Zoom now
Zoom it's like it's like Zoom little
base time we're back in we're back in
human interaction now right what does
Lincoln say uh circulate amongst the
troops yeah so I think we're going for
this correction I'm talking about is
that we've gone from like completely
relying on technology for two years so
like all right let's just get back to
normal and essentially a lot of these
layoffs are because of that Tom what do
you think about this whole conversation
about relationships with robots I'm
actually I want to ask it in a more
serious way possible you your dad was a
rocket scientist you're a guy that went
through IBM's training you're a guy that
was a professor at biolo Adjunct
professor at Pepperdine you've been all
over the place you've been in technology
you've been in it you've been studying
following this industry for a while so
you know the Good Bad and the Ugly do
you think it'll come to a point where
people will be dating robots and they're
going to be replacing relationships all
that stuff well I have two very distinct
thoughts yes the first is
um don't worry about the robots it's
just jobs are going to be different and
people are going to do different jobs
it's like when the when the saddle
Tanner a Tanner is a guy that works with
leather and when the saddle Tanner saw
the first car he's like oh man my my
saddle business is screwed if this
catches on right because he's making
saddles for horses and all that kind of
stuff and these waves go through the
economy and technology and advancement
happen the jobs are different point one
point two if you go look back at the
dawn of
the last like five technology Cycles
the internet
DVDs by the way
um you know what drove D you know what
um drove multi-prospective DVDs remember
you could watch a movie and change your
perspective on it porn
porn and CES Consumer Electronic Show
tried to keep it off to the side porn
was took full advantage of VHS they took
full advantage of DVD porn talk about
the internet and and what happened there
there's always been an element where
people use technology to fulfill vices
so that I think that's gonna happen with
robots and I think it's bad for
relationships I think it's bad for the
human relationship but we've seen it
happen before with technology and Pat
think about this we're kind of joking
around I'm joking about it but you know
I'm a freaking comedian but what I'm
saying is bad thing about this it's
people like us obviously we wouldn't you
guys you know girlfriends married
whatever whatever I'm not talking about
the average guy that just watches porn
on their phone and we're not paying for
it it's the guy that you know like they
get the subscription they're watching it
they're alone trust me those guys you
give them the opportunity of a robot
that's in the house that they can hook
up with and dude what was that movie
Joaquin Phoenix uh do you guys um it was
just her her it was um Scarlett
Johansson was just a robot in his ear
and he was had a relationship bro wait
till that becomes the darkest most
annoying movie annoying movie Pat but
look at how it was horrible it was just
the top 10 worst movies I've seen and I
love Joaquin Phoenix he's one of my
favorite thing about how cheap that
movie was to make just her voice and his
head that said walk around the office he
was uh they made like Hallmark cards we
should make a a version of that yeah
from like a low budget and we should
call it him he him
two different just like don't do it and
it's you in a room
yeah hey what what I just I can't I'm
trying to have a relationship with my ex
I don't know by the way the more I think
about it here's here's what you're
making me think about so okay so porn
was what VHS yes I'm trying to buy the
original movie covered sealed of Rocky
one and all in this one auction and the
uh Godfather but the first one was VHS
okay camera VHS it was
VHS you know in the army barracks it's
got like a thousand porn VHS is on top
of each other who said this one's the
best one this one's this so then you go
DVD then you're saving files on a
computer then it went Napster then it's
phone easy what is the the main site
it's called whatever the new porn sites
are there's a couple of big ones and
then from there you're gonna go virtual
reality what you're doing after virtual
virtual realities they're doing that so
maybe the next phase after virtual
reality is going to be where some guy's
gonna have a robot I'm gonna take a
lunch break he goes on his lunch break
why is your truck going up and down
her it's her my V2 2200 it's a you know
2029 model I just bought for 17 grand
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign